two spheres one with radius seven and
one let's make one with radius seven and
one with let me do n one and one with
radius four are tangent to each other if
p is any point on one sphere and q is
any point on the other sphere what is
the maximum possible length of p cube so
let's think about this
so let me draw the the sphere with
radius seven and obviously a sphere is a
three dimensional object i'm going to
try to draw it in two dimensions
so a circle you could kind of view as a
cross section
of it
so
this right over here
cross section at its widest point of the
sphere
so it has radius seven
so it has radius seven and it is tangent
to
another sphere that has radius 4.
so it has radius
it has radius 4 so the other one might
look something like this once again
it's a cross section it's tangent at
exactly this point and i've just drawn
circles but this you can imagine this
these are these are actually spheres so
i'll try to give it some
some actual depth so that you recognize
that this these are not just you can
imagine balloons or balls of of this
shape now
p is any point on one sphere and q is
any point on the other sphere and we
want the maximum length of pq so we want
to get these points p and q as far away
as possible from each other
so
if i was just dealing with two circles
i'd stick p right over here all the way
here and i would stick q
i would stick q all the way over there
on the other circle and so the distance
between them is going to be essentially
the sum of the two diameters so it's
going to be
it's going to be 14
plus
14 plus 8
and 14 plus 8
14 plus
8 is going to be equal to 22. and so if
i could do that with two circles of
these radii i could obviously do these
as spheres as well you can imagine these
are the cross sections of those spheres
so i can get to a distance of 22 but am
i sure that that's the furthest distance
well you could reason through it that
look if you were to try to bring
bring p out a little bit more onto the
surface here on the surface yeah there's
going to be a little bit of distance now
that it's kind of going out of the page
if you're if you're going out of the
surface right here but it's getting
closer essentially along the page so
maybe those two things trade off or
maybe this really is the maximum
distance and if you're taking this on a
standardized test this could become a
very involved thought process that you
start saying well how do i prove that
this is absolutely the furthest distance
but many times the test itself is
designed so that you don't have to prove
it because notice we can definitely find
a distance of 22. this we can definitely
find between two points on these two
surfaces and notice that is the largest
of all of their possible choices so
we would go with the largest of their
all
all of their possible choices this would
be a little bit more confusing you would
have to be a little bit more rigorous
with yourself and say well you know do i
really know that if they had a choice
that said
23 or a choice that said 22 times the
square root of you know of two or
something like that but the fact that
you can definitely can get these points
to be 22 away from each other and that
is the largest of all of the choices
that's a pretty good clue that that is
the maximum possible length of pq in a
future video i could do a more in-depth
proof that this is actually going to be
the case